[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con cerca de
4000 proyectos de desarrollo sostenible
son liderados por la agencia francesa de
desarrollo en territorios ultramar y
también en 115 países la compañía
proparco es el brazo financiero que
respalda esta labor por eso vamos a
conversar con philips ejes director
regional de proparco para américa del
sur gracias por estar con nosotros señor
serres en france 24 que tan relevante es
el aporte de proparco a los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible que debe cubrir
francia es que ya son 40 años de su
compañía trabajando en países de la
región desde una visión francófona y
también tienen presencia en áfrica en
asia y medio oriente
buenos días muchas gracias pues proparco
definitivamente contribuyen fuertemente
a alcanzar los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible hay que mencionar que en esos
40 años llevamos solamente si no puede
ser así 13 años en américa latina pero
en estos 13 años hemos ya aportado cerca
de 3.9 billones de dólares al
financiamiento de desarrollo sostenible
en américa latina a través del sector
privado con un enfoque tanto en la lucha
contra el cambio climático como en la
inclusión social entre los más
desfavorecidos ya sea financiando
empresas bancos proyectos de
infraestructura o fondo de fondos de
inversión entonces definitivamente
hacemos parte de una arquitectura de
apoyo al desarrollo sostenible dentro
del marco de la cooperación bilateral
francesa
ahora en qué áreas del desarrollo hacen
inversión y qué diferencia han marcado
para los ciudadanos latinos
y diría que en américa latina' a nuestro
enfoque realmente es el lucha contra el
cambio climático de manera general
buscamos a que por lo menos el 50 por
ciento de nuestros financiación de
financiamientos estén dedicados a la
lucha con el cambio climático esto se
produce en proyectos digamos de de
energía renovable pero también puede ser
en temas como la movilidad eléctrica
como el manejo de desechos como todo lo
que tiene que ver con eficiencia
energética y por ejemplo recientemente
hemos financiado en bogotá
una flota de buses eléctricos 250 nuevos
buses eléctricos que van a reemplazar
antiguos buses que funcionan con diésel
dentro del sistema transmilenio en
particular en las en los barrios de usme
y fontibón con financiamiento de 52
millones de dólares lo cual muestra yo
creo de forma muy muy clara el tipo de
apoyo que equipo aparcó puede
en este tipo de proyectos primero que
todo reduciendo obviamente las emisiones
de carbono y segundo mejorando
finalmente el medio ambiente para los
bogotanos puesto que estamos hablando de
buses que no emiten micro partículas que
no emiten carbono entonces que construir
a lo mejor el medio ambiente hacia
felipe ustedes también se concentran en
el crecimiento del sector privado le
pregunto si está ahí entonces la clave
para el desarrollo sostenible
a ver para explicar un poco por un lado
está la gente tras ese desarrollo en
nuestra casa matriz que se especializa
en el financiamiento del sector público
de las políticas públicas de los estados
y probar pos especializar únicamente en
el financiamiento del sector privado
ahora nosotros tenemos la firme
convicción que financia el sector
cuidado también contribuye fuertemente
al desarrollo sostenible puesto que las
empresas son finalmente las fuentes
principales de empleo las fuentes
principales de recursos para lavar las
familias entonces asegurarnos que las
empresas hagan su trabajo finalmente de
forma virtuosa y generando empleo
decente sin generar polución o por lo
menos disminuyendo la producción de
contaminación ambiental es algo es algo
clave por eso que desde hace 40 años
existe esa simbiosis esa
complementariedad entre lo que hace
programa la agencia francesa desarrollo
y por el otro
financiando el sector privado y eso lo
hacemos como lo decía con todo tipo de
identidad bancos gestiones financieras
no bancarias en todo tipo de empresas
proyectos de infraestructura fondos de
inversión y realmente existe una que
crea una fuerte fuerte interés en este
tipo de apoyo que traemos puesto que
tienen la conciencia que no solamente
está el apoyo financiero que obviamente
es interesante pero también un apoyo en
cuanto a mejores prácticas en cuanto a
una visibilidad internacional que se le
da a estas entidades así es philip
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 gracias también ustedes por
siempre estar ahí el otro lado de la
pantalla es una próxima oportunidad
[Música]